first-time entrepreneurs they're at
whatever a million a month and they're
like okay who am I hiring right now
we've done this enough times to be like
okay at this level you probably need a
controller who has experience going from
a million a month to three million a
month and we'll tell them up front that
we will bring a CFO who has transaction
experience so they're not jostled when
that happens you can't just take your
best closer and make him manager because
he's never done this before so we want
someone who's built at least one or two
sales teams and if we do feel like
there's alignment and they have the
chops because we do skill tests then we
can say hey I think that you'll match
and obviously the founder still has
final say because they have to like the
person otherwise it's not going to work